Jimmy Akina senior lives in the Arctic
Canadian community of Cambridge Bay he's
76 and a retired heavy equipment
operator he's also a master komiteh
craftsman did you fall last time I
started braking on any given day
no matter how bad the weather you'll
find Jimmy outside his home on Mariah
crowed working on these sleds that Inuit
use for hunting trapping and traveling
across the sea ice
[Music]
my lord if you know I'm with them like
it's cold
I couldn't chase don't warm up T or T
cannot ferry warm up shot a little bit
more but one day something did stop
Jimmy from doing what he loved a double
knee replacement in the Canadian city of
Yellowknife after which the hospital
there gave him this to take back home to
the High Arctic here where the weather
gets like this and then I ilish Quinn
from I own the Arctic here I'm in studio
putting this report together now and
realized this is turning into another
one of those stories the South doesn't
understand the North blah blah blah poor
northerners blah blah blah but this
actually isn't one of those stories this
is a story about what happens after the
South is out of the picture and
northerners end up fixing things
themselves so I think the best thing for
now is for this journalist to bow out
get out of the way and let Jimmy O kina
senior take the lead from here Jimmy
over to you but to off to carry stuff
for teaching so I serve a community copy
as you know the leadership for nearby
tools and do you go out on the land loft
I can't afford to be you take I want it
going we can take to Zhang Yao I rely on
us no it's too hard
tickly yeah say better how long does it
take to make this how many days usually
three days so not too hard no first time
and camera testing that can yeah you
like it
yeah he walks on me walk salsa No
[Music]